es un laberinto de manglares entre la
tierra y el mar el manglar se revela
lentamente a lo largo del agua y de sus
meandros bordeados de lianas y raíces
aéreas
estamos en el único parque marino de la
república democrática del congo un
bosque de 25.000 hectáreas en la
desembocadura del río con tomas nfu
conoce todos sus secretos
es un bosque de transición entre el
medio acuático y el terrestre conecta a
los dos medios
y protege la costa contra la erosión
marina
marín es una gran fuente de carbono a
carbón
qué significa que es un elemento
importante
muy importante contra
[Música]
el parque fue creado en 1992 y fue
declarado sitio ramsar es decir humedal
de importancia internacional en 1996 el
sitio está protegido sólo unas pocas
docenas de pescadores pueden vivir aquí
han vivido aquí durante varias
generaciones
bucea todos los días para recoger ostras
de agua dulce conocidas como vivo aquí
cuando uno va al fondo a recoger conchas
la respiración es lo que determina lo
que uno trae de vuelta si uno no tiene
suficiente aliento solo traerá una a la
vez y entonces tendrá que sumergirse
muchas veces para recoger suficientes
después de pescar blog se vuelve a la
isla ki sung a mal él se llama la isla
de las conchas porque está totalmente
cubierta de conchas de ostras sus
habitantes viven allí sin electricidad y
casi sin red telefónica desconectados
del mundo
la alegría de vivir aquí es estar
rodeado de toda esta naturaleza justo al
lado del agua hay comida y son muy
buenas fuentes de proteínas también
utilizamos las ramas de los árboles para
construir nuestras casas y cocinar
un modo de vida respetuoso con el medio
ambiente en un ecosistema
extraordinariamente rico muchas especies
en peligro de extinción se han instalado
aquí como las tortugas golfinas que
vienen a desovar a las playas cada año
sabes cuántos nidos no han explosionado
todavía para protegerlos el personal del
parque traslada los nidos a este lugar y
los vigila hasta que inclusión no hay
depredadores así que si dejamos los
nidos en la naturaleza los cangrejos y
los cuervos nos destruirán la población
también quiere comer carne de tortuga
por eso tenemos miedo porque incluso la
propia población cuando viene de los
nidos coge los huevos y se los lleva es
hora de que estas tortugas macías de esa
mañana vayan al océano atlántico
cristian cuido de ellos durante 50 días
pero sabe que los volver a ver pronto
después de siete años crecerán y tendrán
que volver aquí a poner sus huevos las
hembras siempre vuelven al lugar exacto
en dirección
así que se acuerdan del lugar si son
animales reales ya se han liberado más
de 80.000 tortuguitas en 10 años una
victoria para los guardabosques del
parque 15 guardabosques vigila en esta
joya natural con un presupuesto anual de
menos de 100 mil dólares todos los días
en barco y a pie patrulla en el bosque
para vigilar la fauna y la flora
qué es eso tuyo huellas de antílope
es como si hubiera dos está el otro que
se fue al otro lado ese día la patrulla
encontró una estufa de carbón casera
fabricada por los aldeanos la tala
ilegal es una de las principales
amenazas para los manglares el fenómeno
se acentúa con el crecimiento en la
población cada vez que venimos
organizamos patrullas para destruir todo
esto para desanimarnos pero hay personas
que lo siguen haciendo algunos nos dicen
pero no tenemos trabajo que vamos a
hacer aunque la región es rica en
biodiversidad la población local vive en
la extrema pobreza ni el turismo ni la
explotación petrolera en alta mar han
beneficiado a la población local así que
aunque la construcción de un puerto de
aguas profundas en bananas a apenas 500
metros del manglar preocupa a ciertos
científicos la sociedad civil local
tiene menos reservas al respecto
en primer lugar nos aseguramos de que el
puerto se construya en el límite
previsto en el pliego de condiciones
y el ecosistema no se ve afectado por
los grandes buques
no qué posición nuestra posición es
clara es apoyar un proyecto que nos
aportará desarrollo
en vez de él o como según el gobierno
congoleño el proyecto no tendrá un gran
impacto en el manglar y creará miles de
puestos de trabajo hasta la fecha no se
ha hecho público ningún estudio de
impacto ambiental